okay guys this is the 14th of January
today my name is Jess and you're
watching games but news here's the stuff
that mattered to them io interactive has
confirmed that the next hitman game is
going to be fully episodic despite
insisting that hitman would be a full
game the plan is now to release episodes
periodically throughout the course of
tinea the prologue and first mission
will come out as planned on March 11
while other content previously promised
to arrive at launch such as the Italy
and Morocco missions will now be
released in April and May respectively I
am interactive are promising regular
monthly content updates through the end
of this year that will include missions
in the three new settings of Thailand
the US and Japan as well as weekly live
events concerning the move to a purely
episodic format I are both honey secret
explained part of that decision is for
that little bit of extra time to ensure
every location we release is that the
quality level fitting for a hitman game
of the main driving reason is that this
will allow us to create a living game
that will expand and evolve over time
and establish a foundation for the
future you'll be able to pick up the
full game digitally for 60 bucks or the
inter packs are 15 a disc version is
planned for the end of the year should
you find yourself playing on ps4 you'll
have access to exclusive content called
the starry over 6 which consists of
extra missions for each location a beta
for the game is later to begin in
February and io reveal details of a
collector's edition which was designed
using fan feedback you can grab the full
details on this story in our article on
gamespot sci-fi Space Flight Simulator
elite dangerous has now sold over 1.4
million copies across PC Mac and xbox
one that figure represents copies sold
through the end of December 2015 on top
of that developer frontier have said the
average playtime per person is an insane
60 hours early dangerous was
successfully kick-started back in 2012
arrived on PC in December 2014 and on
mac and Xbox one in 2015 frontier CEO
David braven explained that in total
players have racked up 84 million hours
in the game so far and added that
they'll be revealing more updates for
the recently released horizons expansion
very soon finally the critically
acclaimed Bayonetta 2 is being
rereleased on where you this time as a
physical standalone game Nintendo of
America revealed that the retail version
of the game will be available for 30 bux
comes every 19 so it's already available
on its own for fifty dollars on the
Nintendo eShop the original physical
edition came packaged with the first
fame as a game which was previously only
a ps3 and 360 title this bundle has
become particularly difficult to find a
safer places like eBay where you'll
probably be spending above the
recommended retail price to get your
hands on it gamespot have contacted
Nintendo to see if they have plans to
bring the bundle back to shelves let me
know down in the Commerce of your keen
on the idea of playing an episodic
hitman game and why or why not you can
add the game subtle we've got stories on
a call of duty lawsuit and the crew can
you patch that is everything I want to
tell you about today but do be sure to
pop back tomorrow where I'll have the
five best stories of the entire week I
will catch you then